Chúng tình gình nắng nắng kéo dài trên dẫn dọng tại nhiều địa phương.
Bộ y tế đã có chỉ đạo yêu cầu các cơ dở y tế hình chương trình hai các biệt pháp phòng,
trong nắng nắng nhằm bảo vệ su khỏe người bệnh và nhân viên y tế.
Các biệt cần chuẩn bị đầy đủ thuốc, chàng thiết bị phương tiện cấp cứu trong bằng ngoài viện,
tổ chức tập hón, hương giẫn kiến năng sự chí các tiền hỗ nhiều xây nắng,
xúc nhìn, đô quyết, nhằm sẵn sẵn ứng phó và cấp cứu kiến thời.
Đông thời, các đơn vị y tế cần phối hợp với cơ quan trình thông và y tế sự phòng đề mạnh tương trình,
hương giẫn người dân chủ động phòng tránh tắc hại nắng vả những thay đổi nhìn độ đồ nột.
Cục quản lý khám, chữ bệnh phủ yêu cầu các cơ dở giả sóa việc thực hiện các tiêu chi trong bộ tiêu chi
rất lượng bệnh viện hai chấm không.
Như tăng cường thông khi tại sản chờ, thành la, lắp đặt mái chai tại các lối đi ngoài chơi,
bộ xung qua, mái điều ngoài trong điều kiện cho phép.
ngoài ra, các bệnh viện cần bộ chi cũng cóp đề đủ nước uống với phi tại các khoa lâm sàng,
sản chờ, đáp ứng yêu cầu giả tăng trong những ngày nắng nắm, nhằm đăng cao chất lượng phục vụ và sự hai lòng của người bệnh.